buenas noches santi desde el monumento a
los héroes como puedes ver el clima el
ambiente es tranquilo es incluso festivo
y es un clima que ha regido en los otros
puntos de concentración que hay en
bogotá y que también han dominado todo
el país que a destacar que esta es la
tercera semana de protestas en el país y
como comentabas la nota
señalada aquí en bogotá ha sido la
presencia en las calles del senador de
izquierda y candidato a la presidencia
gustavo petro quien el día de ayer había
llamado a los colombianos a salir a las
calles también en el día de ayer se
conoció que el director ejecutivo de
human rights watch josé miguel vivanco
anunció que habían tenido denuncias de
al menos 55 muertes desde el inicio de
las protestas y el lunes el presidente
iván duque anunció el despliegue máximo
de fuerza pública para detener el
desabastecimiento que está generando los
bloqueos que hay por distintas vías de
todo el país y que como comentaba están
generando también pérdidas millonarias
para los empresarios en la jornada de
hoy uno de los departamentos más
afectados es risaralda en el occidente
colombiano por el bloqueo de las vías
lluís tampoco prosperó en la jornada de
hoy en la cámara de representantes- esa
propuesta de una reforma a la salud en
colombia pudo
entonces la presión social porque era
también uno de los grandes reclamos de
estas movilizaciones ciudadanas
desde que iniciase en las protestas el
28 de abril ya ha caído una reforma
tributaria ha caído un ministro de
hacienda la canciller y hoy la reforma
de la salud en el congreso los
manifestantes han considerado que esto
es una victoria de las calles de la
presión social de las protestas que está
viviendo el país desde hace tres semanas
sin embargo también ahora se entra en
una nueva fase en un nuevo contrato
social en las negociaciones entre el
gobierno de iván duque pone el comité
nacional de paro siga nuestras
negociaciones para los jóvenes para
muchos manifestantes aquí concentrados
no son válidas ya que ellos exigen que
para poder empezar a hablar el gobierno
tendría que el gobierno tendría que
condenar completamente la violencia
policial ya que consideran que han
vivido desde el inicio